foreign
Health isn't eating you know the right
amount of calories and proteins fats and
carbs and exercising all the time
sometimes healthy eating is you know hey
I haven't seen my friend in in a year
and we're gonna go get some pizza and
have some beer sometimes that's healthy
usually it's not
sometimes
it is hey what's up what's up this is
John with the Dr John deloney show the
greatest mental health in marriage and
parenting podcast ever recorded
hope you're doing well and I'm so glad
that you have given us your most
precious precious precious your most
precious resource your time I'm grateful
you're here and this is also a show
about Linguistics because I'm such a
clear talker good good grief uh hey
don't forget to leave your five star
reviews and share these episodes with
folks that
um you think would benefit from them and
if you will subscribe it just helps kick
the sucker up into the algorithms and it
helps more people that would didn't
would otherwise not know about the show
helps them to see the show so thank you
so much it's a way you can support us
and help other people out in your
communities without having to pay for
anything y'all are getting having to pay
for everything these days and so it's a
good way to help out without out with
very little effort
um all right so today's show it's a
different show in fact it's a show we've
never done before
um and I need to tell you it's one of
the most impactful
hour and a half I've ever spent with
somebody
um I went to San Jose California to be
on the Mind pump show with Sal de
Stefano and gang
and it was a we ended up going I think
about an hour over on their podcast and
it ended up being a great episode for
their crew but I stayed and recorded an
episode of the Dr John deloney show with
Sal in their Studio
and so I need you to know this I talked
about things publicly that I've never
spoken about to somebody other than my
wife including my challenges with
disorder eating and body dysmorphia and
some of the struggles I've been lifting
weights for 30 years and some of the
struggles I've had trying to navigate
fitness and what it's working out look
like and exercise so Sal is a master
a master the whole gang is at making
exercise simple
and he has him and his team the Mind
pump crew have made it their mission to
go after the fitness industry the
nonsense they're all been personal
trainers for decades
um they have been coaches for decades
they trained coaches
and they are just extraordinary human
beings and so uh buckle up this is a
long uh interview and I'm not even gonna
wrap it up at the end so when the
interview's over the show will be over
um because I don't want to waste your
time but this is a transformative
interview my life has been different
since this interview has ended and I've
implemented some of the not some a lot
of the changes Kelly's like those of us
who are in the interview we all left
California with our lives different so
um this is about exercise this is about
nutrition this is about mental health
this is about relationships this is
about living and creating a life worth
living
stay tuned for my interview with the
great Sal de Stefano
all right Sal dude thanks for letting me
be in your house yeah thanks for coming
this is our first show in somebody
else's house is it really yes how do you
like our studio
if I'm being super honest yeah it's
super it's way cooler than mine that's
not gonna say something bad no you got
guitars on the wall you have yeah this
is rad thank you thing we just put it
together to make it look more visual
it's it's legit man appreciate it thank
you all for Hospitality appreciate it
Whatever Whenever we meet folks you
always wonder like all right are they
gonna
be cool yeah yeah super hospital I mean
I'm super super grateful thank you
um okay so we're gonna talk about a
couple of things that are a big deal
um to me personally and if the listeners
are in on it that's cool okay so I want
to talk about your new book uh it's been
out for a year the resistance training
Revolution uh we're having a
conversation about on the airplane and
just the folks that travel with me were
like what what right and the second is
you've been working with Trainers for
years and so you we talked about earlier
getting behind like the the meal plan
and the weight loss why are people
struggling the way they're struggling
yeah right and so let me start off this
way
um what happened
what happened to the fitness and the
diet like what happened because the more
I'm learning the simpler it's getting
but I consider myself somebody who's up
on the science knows what I'm talking
about and dude I was so so lost at sea
man what happened yeah so you could say
it's both very simple and very complex
and also the way that we've tried to
tackle the problem was come from the
wrong angle completely which is why we
failed okay uh so terribly so let's
start with the I guess the Obesity or
poor health epidemic
um in in a nutshell or environment
changed far faster than our ability to
develop
um I guess guidelines or structures or
behaviors around that new environment
and so the the result of which has been
poor health but to be more specific
um I know in the 80s so I'm I'm you know
I remember I'm old enough to remember
you know obesity being blamed on fat and
then it got blamed on carbohydrates and
you know who knows what they're gonna
blame on next maybe protein
um but you know so I'm old enough to
remember that and also old enough to see
how they were wrong on all of that
really what a lot of it has to do with
um and poor health is quite complex but
obesity a lot has to do with just the
consumption of heavily processed foods
okay and it's not that these foods are
inherently unhealthy although many of
them are
it's that these foods are engineered uh
to make us overeat and there's some
really really good studies on this so if
you like looking at data and studies or
some excellent studies done on heavily
processed foods where they take groups
of people and one of the challenges with
nutrition studies or Diet studies is a
lot of them are observational yeah or
you know they have to come in and kind
of report and how many tomatoes did you
have last year yeah it's super it's
super inaccurate but these studies were
really good because they were controlled
they actually took people put them in a
lab and they said okay you group over
here you have unlimited access to whole
Natural Foods whole Natural Foods being
foods with like one or two ingredients
like bananas apples steak you know that
kind of stuff and then the other groups
like okay you guys have unlimited access
to heavily processed foods so these are
foods that are in wrappers and boxes
things with long shelf life and they
actually even exactly and they and they
actually even
controlled the macro content so it's
like similar proteins fats and carbs
some of the proteins fats and carbs they
had them stay in those rooms for a while
and observe them and then they switched
groups which is I love this part they
took this group put them in this room
took this group put them in that room
and what they found on average is that
people consume about five to six hundred
more calories a day when they heavily
process foods and that's again because
these foods are engineered to make us
over eat and if you look at if you
really want to put your finger on the
main culprit although like I said it's
complex if you want to put your finger
on the main culprit if you look at the
the predominance of heavily processed
foods in the American diet it starts off
very small but then it rapidly becomes a
majority of our diet you'll see that it
almost mirrors the Obesity epidemic you
just lay that map right on top of the
other one and you'll see that really
almost starts to mirror so to give
another good example
um of kind of what I'm talking about
um we had um Chris Kresser on the show a
few years ago and he gave this wonderful
analogy and I use it all the time now
and he said look if I took
five boiled plain potatoes I just boil
them in water give them to you no salt
no butter and said here eat all these
you probably wouldn't be able to do it
after about two potatoes you'd gag and
you'd get what's called pallet fatigue
but if I gave you a large family-sized
bag of Lay's potato chips which contains
roughly four to five potatoes you could
probably eat them all you could crush it
that's right yeah and so what's happened
is is all the research and development
that's gone into heavily processed foods
the vast majority that goes into
understanding and hacking how to get us
to eat more of these Foods it sells more
product but what it's done is it's
hijacked our systems of satiety
and so there's this belief that humans
are eating machines if you just put food
in front of us we'll just eat until we
die that's not that's not really true we
do have
um satiety that kicks in we do get
palate fatigue right we've all
experienced this we eat dinner you're
full I can't eat any more than they
bring out dessert all of a sudden you
feel like you can my kids call it uh my
dessert stomach is is doing great right
now right so and and this is this is a
very interesting phenomena we have this
so we can actually so our bodies will
tell us to stop eating because
evolutionarily speaking it was bad to
overeat just like now just like it was
back then
um and there's lots of reasons right you
could overeat poor digestion you would
have died geez you got diarrhea a
thousand years ago who knows it that
might have been in your life right so so
but again these foods have hijacked
those and so when you eat a lot of these
Foods I mean you can apply discipline
you could try to like no I'm not gonna
eat any more but it's it's it's it's
almost a losing it's it is a losing
battle it really is but how do we get
from that to blaming the consumer oh
because because the consumer does I mean
I do have some responsibility not eating
those chips and at the same time man I'm
fighting a whole bunch of scientists who
have like engineered it to make me not
one of them I am not blaming the
producers because they're a market
they're just giving us more of what we
want okay okay and we're just feeling
Gap and markets are really good at that
okay they'll give us what we want and
what do we want convenience and we want
the hedonistic pleasure from the food we
want that that feeling so we got it yeah
um how do we how do we get that
responsibility well first we have to
become aware we have to become aware
that look these Foods
my body perceives them different than
other Foods yeah I'll give you a an
interest like really really effective
tip that I use with clients and it took
me a few years to kind of figure this
out so early in my career I wasn't a
great trainer and later on I became a
good trainer because I didn't do a good
job and I really had to figure out yeah
reps right what it took to do well and
early in my career I would do things
like hey Mrs Johnson I want you to cut
your calories by 500 calories and I'd
have her track and do all that stuff and
so like every day here's your calorie
Target and just do this and you'll get
great results well that didn't work uh
long term it never does later on what I
would do is I'd tell clients hey eat as
much as you want eat until you're
satisfied just avoid heavily processed
foods and they'd say okay and they would
get the same results as if they cut the
500 calories and it was again because
our bodies will eat more or less what's
appropriate when we remove those types
of foods out of our diet and that's just
one piece and there's a lot more that
goes into this our approach towards
weight loss has been all wrong both
mechanistically
but the big issue is that we're view we
we tend to view humans as like robots
you plug in the numbers and you'll get
the result and I did this as a trainer
oh you want to lose weight here's your
meal plan here's your workout just
follow this and you're going to be
totally fine as though weight loss is uh
solely due to a lack of correct
information it it it it doesn't work
data right yeah I mean food alone I mean
gosh
food is proteins fats carbs calories and
nutrients but is that all it is culture
man it's laughter it's Joy it's hanging
out with your friends your family big
Italian family it's it's everything it's
the centerpiece it's connecting it's I'm
depressed it's I'm anxious it's I'm at
the movies so these kinds of foods yeah
it's uh I'm you know breakfast foods and
lunch foods and dinner foods so to try
to simplify diet all the way down to eat
this don't eat that here's your calories
is really ignoring how we really value
food and what it means to us it's this
huge part of who we are and it's a big
part of our behaviors and if unless we
tackle it that way we're gonna we're
gonna fail and all look diets have
85 fail rate and this is within the
first year
um you stretch that out to five years I
bet that number gets north of 95 percent
and and that's the other problem we
don't need to figure out new ways of
losing weight we do a good job by the
way losing weight millions of Americans
lose weight every single year we got to
tackle the real issue which is how do we
keep it off keep it off now what's the
problem why are we all gaining the
weight back
um and I do talk about in the book
um a lot of the reasons why I think
we're getting the weight back so
yesterday A friend of mine
um called This is literally I'm in on
the streets of San Jose take a step out
take a call and they said hey I went to
the doctor and like looked at me and he
mentioned probably five times I need to
lose some weight and we've let him know
that for years just as one of our
friends
and he said he gave me this list of all
these different diets I can try and
whichever ones and he's like so which
one of these
what do I we're at a point now or I told
him I said I don't have a great answer
for other than you got to make peace
with why you eat too much and you gotta
quit drinking and
that wasn't a mechanistic well he told
me to try intermittent fasting he told
me to try a high fats and if that didn't
work then I could probably try a vegan
diet
like you just got to make peace with why
I eat like
that probably wasn't a great answer for
him just me walking on the street on the
cell phone like
what do you tell somebody that because
that's the person listening to the show
right now right they're an over the road
trucker they just want to be a little
bit better dad they're a busy busy busy
mom whose husband's running around what
do you tell that person who's like there
you gotta you gotta cut about 30 40
pounds you actually gave him good advice
really yeah you never give good enough
yeah that was a great one okay so you
want to know what's funny if you look at
the data long term okay so we all look
at that like how much weight did they
lose in a three-month period ignore that
yep how much weight did they lose
forever that's what we got to look at if
you look at the data the most effective
stress if we were to compare diets
diets to therapy therapy is more
effective you take someone who's obese
and you haven't see a counselor and they
go to a counselor or a therapist and
they say uh yeah I just have this issue
with food
they'll have more success
I don't even know that that's true now I
I as a trainer I figured this out later
on and I would work with my clients and
therapists and my success rate went
through the roof and this is how I
learned this is one of the ways I
learned a lot of my strategies was by
hearing how these therapists would
communicate to these people I'll give
you a great example okay
um most people enter into a diet or a
workout program
from a place of self-hate that's okay I
don't I I look gross I'm not sexy I'm
too skinny I'm too fat whatever okay so
they're going into it from a place of
self-hate
when you hate yourself diet becomes
restriction exercise becomes punishment
so when I used to manage gyms I would
see this all the time people would come
to the gym and they would value the
workout based on how much pain they felt
and how hard they sweat and how sore
they got why it was cathartic because
they had to punish themselves I'm so
overweight I'm gonna go beat myself how
many times have you heard this that's me
man yeah well that's most people you
describing me yeah that's most people
how many times have you heard people say
um oh man I ate so much pizza pizza
yesterday I'm gonna go and just sweat it
out and beat myself up yeah right so
that right it's no wonderful yeah okay
so I'll tell you a story where this
really
where this really
um became it was Illuminating to me this
particular conversation so I was at a
dinner with my ex-wife so she used to
work for a tech company and they would
have these like big dinners where you
can meet spouses and whatever and we're
I'm hanging out with all these you know
all her co-workers and their spouses and
we're all introducing ourselves and um
you know as a trainer whenever I
introduce myself
um of course people all of a sudden
become self-aware of like the food
they're eating so you know oh you know
my name's Sal and I you know I own a gym
or whatever of course people are like oh
don't look at me I'll have another glass
of wine don't make fun of me or whatever
so that kind of starts out at first but
then everybody got comfortable and as
the wine started flowing I remember this
lady
sitting across from me she goes you know
Sal she goes I had a friend
who you know she was 48 years old
exercise all the time ate right whatever
and then she got cancer and she died and
so I just said you know what I'm just
gonna enjoy my life I'm just gonna enjoy
my life and I'm gonna eat everything and
drink and just you know forget exercise
and I sat there really quiet and you
know I empathize with her and I sat
there and it hit me and I said what a
strange thing to say
that because we know this it's a fact if
you eat right and you exercise the
quality of your life improves
dramatically oh there's almost nothing
that that won't improve if you're
healthier that you're better parent
better employee innovate better more
productive everything right I said gosh
she said she just wants to enjoy her
life so she's not going to do those
things and I've heard that so many times
I thought how can that be
oh I know exercise is a punishment and
diet is restriction it's they go into it
with a self-hate I hate myself they
divide themselves into two different
people
the child that needs to be tyrannized
don't do that don't do this you're gross
whatever and eventually you leave
because why you rebel I don't want to do
this anymore this sucks I don't want to
punish myself I don't restrict myself
I'm a grown-up I can do whatever I want
yeah yeah by the way this is why when
people go off a diet they don't go and
have one cookie oh they have a box of
them in a bag dude yeah they are
rebelling against that in that because
that psychological phenomena that
happens what if people did this instead
what if people went into diet and
exercise like this instead of looking in
the mirror and says oh I look gross I'm
disgusting I'm gonna go beat myself up
or whatever what if they said you know
what
I haven't been taking care of myself and
I deserve to be taken care of just like
anybody else you know what I'm gonna
start doing I'm gonna start taking care
of myself like somebody I care about and
then they go to the gym and they do what
they train themselves appropriately they
don't overdo it they don't beat the crap
out of themselves they go in there and
the goal is to feel better right what
about diet I get to I don't have to yeah
now the diet is balanced you offer me
that cookie it's I can't have it it's uh
you know I actually don't want it I know
how I know how I don't feel good after
that yes or yeah I'll have that color
I'm all in yeah because you know here's
the thing about health we talk about
this a lot on the show
health
isn't eating you know the right amount
of calories and proteins fats and carbs
and exercising all the time health is is
a is a sphere and it's quite balanced
sometimes healthy eating is you know hey
I haven't seen my friend in in a year
and we're gonna go get some pizza and
have some beer yeah yeah sometimes
that's healthy yeah usually it's not
sometimes it is though right right and
that's how you develop that balance
that's how you have that cookie and not
to eat the whole box and it's not
because you can't it's because that's
what you want and you know if we can get
people and this is what I eventually
figured out how to do is to get people
to develop that relationship with
exercise and diet and then they do it
forever it's not uh um I gotta force
myself or I have to you know feel
motivated which is another issue yeah
yeah yes so I'll let me forget these
questions we'll just this will be a
therapy session for me
um
I've struggled with body dysmorphia for
a long time and for those of you
listening it's it's this idea that I
don't care what the objective data says
I don't care what my wife says I don't
hurt my friends and how my clothes fit
it's what I see in the mirror isn't good
enough and I gotta keep pushing and keep
pushing
I've reached a point now where
I exercise because if I simply feel
better right and I now know if I eat
this I I doing some some work on trying
to be a better parent I recognize if I
eat this whole pizza which I could
polish one off on a Friday night I won't
sleep very well I'll be up and down up
and down I'll be a little bit grumpier
Saturday morning then my kids will come
in and I'll be a little bit more dead
Pokey and they'll be a little bit more
separate which then sets off some of my
childhood stuff and then I'll be like
hey guys and get a little bit louder and
all sudden nobody wants to be around dad
and that and by Sunday morning I'm
Sunday afternoon Dad I'm I am
frustrating to be around I've got that
ball of energy I'm starting to dread
Monday
all that can be traced back to that that
Friday night so I'm pretty intuitive
when it comes to that
I haven't made the leap to my wife's my
wife uh over Christmas this is her great
quote uh my family was there pretty sure
I'd covered I wasn't feeling good
um we had a whole bunch of drama going
on and I was like I just gotta go down
and get a workout in
she looked at me and goes stop I was
like nah I just need to go down a lift I
have gym in the in the basement
and she said 15 John
I was like what is that and she said of
all of the total of the reason I love
you how you look is 15 and she said it's
maxed out you look good you look good
all 15 yeah and hey I was like it's got
to be way more than 15 but
she was saying you don't need anymore I
don't need any more from you in that in
that area but for me I couldn't I
haven't made that leap yet so I feel
like the bar moves on me right I lose 10
pounds cool I just I need 10 pound more
I need to get a little bit bigger a
little bit smaller how do you stop the
bar because I feel like I'm on a
treadmill that I can't get off yeah it's
a process and it's definitely a journey
um you're gonna learn that lesson one
way or another so what I mean by that is
yeah man well everybody gets older yeah
you know if you look at Celebrities
these Hollywood celebrities you can't
let it go you can see the ones that are
um so connected their identity so much
about their youth and their appearance
that you could see that they are very
distorted um and they're unhealthy and
we see this in the health and fitness
space quite a bit we talked about this
earlier when you were on our show
um Myspace has got more eating disorders
and body dysmorphia than almost any
other space so you'll figure it out but
I think the key is
um your father
okay we take care of our kids better
than we take care of ourselves all day
okay so I do that to myself and by the
way I started working out because the
body dysmorphia and I probably still
struggle with it from time to time as
well and I gotta remind myself what am I
taking care of myself like I would take
care of my son or my daughter and then
that's the answer that's the right
answer even if I don't want to do it
that'll usually point me in the right
direction because I'm a better I take
care of my kids like I said better and
as a trainer by the way I was a better
trainer for my clients than I was all
day yeah for myself because I'm a way
better counsel for the people than for
myself totally right so there's that the
other part is if you do this long enough
you know Fitness one of the things I
love about Fitness
is that it's this really unassuming
vehicle of personal growth it's
unassuming because nobody goes into it
thinking I'm going to do this personal
growth thing and become this better
person everybody's like I want to lose
weight look better I want to look sexy I
want to look at a bikini right but if
you follow it long enough what do you
learn acceptance like you know at some
point I accept it as a kid I ain't gonna
look like Arnold Schwarzenegger it's not
going to happen I don't got a genetics
it ain't gonna happen but I still do it
right or um I'm getting older I'm not as
strong as I used to be I still do it
anyway right so there's that acceptance
there's the
um I suck I suck at stuff like the first
time you do a squat you're not gonna be
good at it right how do you get good at
you keep doing it you're practicing
pull-ups yeah you learn that right you
go through the this is what I gotta do
to look a particular way and then you
start to go well that's what I gotta do
to feel a particular way and then you go
wait there maybe there's more to health
than just exercise and diet maybe I look
at this meditative practice or
spirituality or all these different
things so you start to figure it out so
long as you appreciate the journey so if
you appreciate the journey you know like
oh you know I've gone through periods of
my life that were really challenging you
know years ago I had this was like back
to back it was like in a two-year period
I had a friend of sorry a family member
very close family member that uh lost a
struggle with cancer and it was a long
battle and I was very close to them and
then shortly after I went through a
divorce now during that whole period of
time the exercise for me was not about
hitting PRS it was not about looking
better I went in there because
um I needed it I needed I needed to
disconnect from some of that stuff focus
on me for a second feel better for a bit
keep myself healthy enough so I could
deal with these other things right so
it's that Journey process like why do
you value the exercise is it because it
makes you look good well eventually
you'll learn that that's you're gonna
have to let go of it is that I guess
yeah eventually you just do it because
you enjoy the process and if you do that
well I mean then you'll then you'll
never really stop but it is a process I
don't I don't know how long that process
probably of Life probably lifelong but I
I bet you you've been how long you've
been working out now oh my my whole life
yeah so I bet your your body image stuff
is probably better now than it was 20
years absolutely and just just hearing
that makes me want to approach this
anytime I read or hear objective wisdom
or data and it conflicts with what I'm
feeling
my feelings are what needs to change
usually right and so this is a good
place to be curious about it so the next
time I feel less than just to ask
what is it where is it what is my body
trying to protect me from why does it
why is it announcing that we don't look
good we need to cover where my wife
always gets on me because I like to wear
a shirt at the pool supply it's like I
don't know you know it does a little kid
yeah
um and so that was one of her requests
for our anniversary trip which is like
we just take your shirt off at a pool at
a public pool like you know I mean
um but it was less about it was more
about I want you to be comfortable in
your own skin and so I think it's it's a
it's a practice right it's a thing I'm
going to lean into it is and again it's
it's the Journey of something I quote
that I've said uh before and funny I was
on another podcast and I said this and
it went viral it's all over the place
now but it's and it's not my wisdom this
is actually ancient wisdom it's that the
man who loves walking is going to walk
further than the man who loves the
destination so you know once you can
once you kind of fall in love with the
journey then you'll never really stop
you'll never stop learning yeah either
and that's the that's the that's where
you want that's the the goal right
that's where you want to be if you're
listening to this and you struggle with
this back and forth relationship like
most people with exercise nutrition you
got to figure out okay how can I fall in
love with this journey part of it is not
falling in love with the goals and the
results that's been big for me yeah and
all those things take care of themselves
if you follow the process listen
um 100 here's another you know another
thing I communicate quite a bit um and
this I had to learn the hard way you
know in my early 30s
I learned this hard lesson because up
until then I was really the Meathead
trainer like I knew exercise right I
knew cardio I knew how to build muscle
and burn body fat and macros and
supplements but it was still very driven
by how I looked my Aesthetics and
identified with muscle and look in a
particular way well anyway I developed
some really bad gut health issues uh in
my early 30s at one point I thought I
had Crohn's disease and I was I lost a
lot of weight loss like 13 14 pounds I
this armor that I had built of muscle
was deteriorating all around me none of
what I knew was solving it
thankfully thank God I had at the time I
had a wellness studio and at least I had
the werewolf all to know that there was
value in other practices so in my studio
I had a gut health expert I had a
hormone specialist I had a functional
medicine practitioner massage therapist
meditative specialist acupuncturist and
they were all in my place right even
though
I it wasn't for me I could see the value
of my clients well anyway here I was
couldn't figure this out losing weight I
I looked terrible so this was really bad
for me right and I sat down with a few
of them and I said that's it I give up
I'll do whatever you guys tell me I
can't nothing I'm doing is helping I
don't know what the hell's going on and
so they said okay here's what we're
gonna do and I followed their advice and
I had to not look in the mirror
in order to follow their advice so I
didn't pay attention to the reflection
in the mirror didn't look at the numbers
on the bar when I was working out and
really my goal became my health how do I
feel how's my digestion how's my energy
how's my sleep that's what I focus on
and I did this for it was about a year
through this process and then I was at a
pool party with some friends
and uh we're at the pool hanging out and
I got up to the bathroom and I walked
into the bathroom and they had there was
like like three mirrors that were
reflecting off each other so I don't
know if this ever happened to you but I
saw a reflection of myself from an angle
that I didn't recognize so in a split
second I saw myself objectively it was
really weird feeling yeah right so I saw
this reflection and I realized it was me
but in that Split Second I objectively
without body image issues without any of
that stuff saw myself and I said oh my
God and I looked in the mirror I said I
look better than I've ever looked
said holy cow who would have thought
chasing Health would have produced this
aesthetic look
um and and that's when I realized you
know if you chase Health you're gonna
get the Aesthetics that you're looking
for great deal of it if you chase the
Aesthetics you'll eventually lose your
health and you'll lose the Aesthetics as
well
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spitting
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free
and that's what therapy can help you do
it gives you the tools you need to do
the problem solving in your own life and
that's why I love better help better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours if you're ready to get the tools
that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloney to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
do we have we gotten too obsessed
um as a culture with goals yeah
I get in in my old world in the
University setting
like you you used to earn a master's
degree on the way to a PhD and all his
word was like somebody handing you a cup
of water on a marathon like you're a
lifetime scholar and we're just gonna
pause and recognize look how far you've
come
and you got the rest of your life to do
this now they become destinations right
I'm gonna go get this certification so
that I can tell the world look how look
how much I know look how many classes I
sat through and I feel like everything's
about a goal here and a goal here and a
goal here as a place to start instead of
saying no what if
sleeping better was your goal or what
about having a better marriage was your
goal and if you pulled that thread long
enough you probably should work out you
should move your body right yeah what's
that phenomenon there's a term for it
where
um you would see this in athletes like
they train their whole life to compete
in the Olympics yes then they get to the
Olympics they win gold and then they get
depressed oh I fall off the map yeah
because her identity was that yeah yeah
that's what happens with a lot of people
you'll see people losing 30 pounds I'm
here
uh oh yeah what do I do now like this is
I don't know if I could do this I don't
enjoy this
um so yeah I think goals are are fine
but I don't think we should worship
goals I think it's really important to
figure out how to enjoy the process you
know because then you're always going to
want to you're always going to want to
do that and part of that is what how you
go into it yeah how do I go into this am
I taking care of me or am I punishing me
is it because I love me or is it because
I hate me you know why am I doing this
if you go into it the right way and then
once you understand that by the way once
you go into the right way there's more
right then we can discuss the mechanisms
in the most effective ways and what's
going to give you the most bang for your
buck and all that stuff which everybody
wants to talk about that's all minor
stuff right and we'll get there we can
get there we'll talk about all that but
you got to go into it the right way if
you go into it the right way then the
stuff I can talk about the mechanisms uh
that work and that help
um then they become very effective and
the parallels with dealing with your
marriage or with mental health is the
exact same like if you go into a
disagreement with your with with my wife
to win we both lost right or if I go in
to show her where she needs we both lost
if I go in like trying to help this
relationship it's totally for
proposition right absolutely it's 100
the same thing and
um
I this again I I found so much value in
working with clients who had therapists
and you know I guess my Saving Grace was
I cared so much about helping my clients
that I was able to question my own
methods when they weren't successful so
at least it dissolved that part of my
ego where I'd say okay this isn't
working
I really care about this person like
what's going on so I work with these
therapists and I'd ask them questions
and like you know how do I communicate
to this person I remember once I had a
client my first first time having a
client that told me they had an eating
disorder I had somebody who was
recovering
um anorexic and uh just I I you know
thankfully I didn't say okay you're
working with a therapist I need to talk
is it okay if I communicate with them so
that I can know the right ways to
approach whatever so talk to this person
they said okay
um don't talk about weight don't talk
about body fat percentage don't talk
about
uh how they look focus on their
performance
and I remember it's like a light bulb oh
yeah let's just see if they would skip
them strong yeah let's just focus on
strength the side effect of which being
you're gonna have to feel better yeah
yeah you gotta eat if you're gonna get
stronger that's right and it worked it
was so effective now you could get
obsessed with that as well but it was a
wonderful segue from body focus to
Performance to all right now I'm gonna
take care of myself
um but yeah that's that's the biggest
thing and and what we've done
there's a few different reasons why we
we failed to solve this one is the how
we go into it I hate myself and then the
fitness space and the health space
capitalizes on that it's very very
powerful short-term motivator if you're
hating yourself right now I can sell you
something real quick you know in fact in
sales I talk about pain points if you
ever take a marketing course they'll
tell you find a person's pain points and
Hammer I never thought though we're
creating them right yeah let's create a
pain point and then solve it right oh
yeah oh create it find it
and and you know hammer on that they'll
buy your product right so there's that
uh the other part is the the motivation
model okay which is and fitness loves
this right the newest class oh my God
it's so exciting Urban Cowboy hip-hop
dance class whatever it's new you know
new exercise machine it's so fun yeah
um and I get it we all love the feeling
of motivation
um I've never had to convince a client
to exercise or eat right when they're
motivated right it's the other times so
we have to learn how to develop skills
of discipline
that stick with us
forever all right let's get on that road
yeah
so we live in a culture that we talked
about this earlier it's all feelings
what do you feel what do you feel like
what do you feel like if you don't feel
like it
um if you feel like you need a raise you
should go get good Demand right and if
you feel like you don't want to pay back
your student loans you should just write
a letter to the Congress like you know
it's all about feelings feelings
and for me when it comes to exercise
when it comes to taking care of my
relationships comes to do my own stuff
feelings get me about 10 yards down the
road man and then I have to
go do the hard stuff I think all mental
health can be summed up and do it anyway
right yeah
um
talk to me about the difference between
motivation and discipline yeah and how
you cultivate motivation motivations of
feeling and um we all go through periods
of motivation we all go through periods
without motivation so if you if you rely
on motivation you're going to eventually
fail when that's gone okay so like 100
yeah marriage parenting all of us yeah
when you don't feel like it if you
haven't developed a way to do it anyway
yes then it's not going to happen when
that feeling is gone and that's true for
all things but especially yeah and I see
that in Fitness uh you know obviously I
saw that all the time with Fitness
so and I like to give people measurable
like step-by-step things
um and this simplifies it but again it's
it's more challenging the way I'm going
to make it sound but I would tell
clients I'd say look here's what we're
going to do
let's start with one step that we can
take that is challenging because it's
got to have meaning if there's no
challenge it doesn't mean anything to
you but also realistic in this context
forever not 30 days 60 days 90 days
until I lose 30 pounds but I want you to
be honest you have to be honest with
yourself is this a step I can take now
that I think it's still challenging but
I think I feel pretty confident that I
can maintain for the rest of my life
okay that means through the times where
you're not motivated when you're tired
whatever okay start there and I don't
care what that step is it could be the
smallest I mean I had a client once the
first step was to read one page out of a
nutrition book once a week that was the
first that's where we settled okay okay
we settled there right so we started
that's the starting point so I don't
care what it is uh you know I'm gonna
drink a glass of water extra every day
or I'm gonna walk for five minutes after
breakfast or I'm gonna go to the gym
once a week whatever it is challenging
but realistic forever start there do
that
when you do that and it feels like a
behavior it feels like something that
you just do now then start over what's
the next step I could take that is
challenging yet realistic forever and
continue down that process and whatever
end up happening through that process is
you end up developing confidence
and you'll develop the skill of
discipline and now here's what it looks
like for people just because I like to
paint this out for people I used to like
doing this for clients it would make me
look like a wizard like I could tell the
future
but this is what it's going to look like
for you that first step is going to be
very small and there's going to be a
period of time between that and the next
step but between each step the time
tends to get shorter and each step tends
to get bigger
it's just generally what happens the
first step is really small the next one
tended a little bit bigger page I'm
gonna read 10 pages and Maria chapter
I'm gonna read a book A Week yes yes and
it gets larger and larger and more
consistent and over time you develop
this skill of discipline and these
behaviors yeah that stick with you
largely forever you know I had a client
once I love telling talking about her I
know she's hurt I'm guaranteed she's
heard me talk about her so and I'll
change her name a little bit because
just in case but I used to train at one
point I had a lot of doctors that were
clients of mine
I used to have my Wellness Studio was
next to a hospital and I trained one
doctor and then they started referring
doctors to me and then they would start
to send me patience and I had one lady
that I trained wonderful general surgeon
and she said hey I got this i got this
patient and I really wanted to see you
she really doesn't want to work out but
she's recovering from cancer and I know
she'll benefit from this so I'm just I'm
I'm working on her well anyway one day
she finally walks in so in comes Kelly
and she's got this look on her face like
she don't want to be there introduce you
know myself to her and she says before
we get started I'm only going to work
out once a week with you I'm not doing
anything on my own and we're not going
to touch my diet
and I said okay no problem that's what
we're going to start yeah now I knew at
this point I was an experienced much
wiser trainer early trainer me would
have totally screwed up on this but I
knew if I did a good job with that once
a week it was only a matter of time
before she would want to do more stuff
on her own and sure enough that's what
happened for one year I trained Kelly
once a week for one year now in that
year she definitely built some strength
we definitely saw improvements in
Mobility her posture got a little bit
better she got a little bit less pain
because she had some chronic pain due to
some movement issues
so she saw some stuff and I made sure to
make the workout super enjoyable for her
so she was a professor so she would come
in very intellectual so we have these
wonderful stimulating conversations when
she would come in and so I knew that she
showed up because half the time she
wanted to come and have these great
conversations which for me I loved it as
well sure so she'd show up once a week
very consistent and that was it well a
year sure enough a year into this she
comes up to me and she says hey um
do you have any more time on your
schedule for for more sessions
absolutely Kelly let's get you in one
more day a week so we did that four
months later
hey Sal are there any any movements I
could do on my own at home you know when
I'm grading papers or you know whatever
yeah here's three movements do these at
home you do them whenever you want
they're going to help some of your
movement issues and I think this will be
good for you
a few months after that you know so I'm
thinking about cutting sugar removing
sugar from my diet or cutting it down
what do you think absolutely anyway
three years later this was a three year
process three years later this woman was
exercising three days a week regularly
she was doing stuff on her own her diet
had radically changed and this woman had
completely transformed her health and
her Fitness now that was
almost 10 years ago I haven't trained
this woman for a long time right that I
stopped training people about six years
ago uh because of you know mind pumping
all that stuff she's still doing it
she's still consistent she's developed
this relationship with exercise and
nutrition but it was through that
process now imagine if she came in
and she said I'm only doing one day a
week
I'm not working out on my own and I'm
not working on my diet and now I can be
very can I can be very convincing I can
throw some charisma at people I was a
real effective sales person early on as
a trainer because of those things and I
could have probably convinced her
through my motivational skills or
whatever no you got to come three days a
week it's gonna make you better at this
and here's that and here's why and
everybody's got the same time of the day
everybody's got the same 24 hours you
could and do the whole speech and maybe
I would have convinced her to hire me
three days a week you know what would
happen for two weeks she would have
stopped that's right she was a few
months into it she would have stopped it
I never would have seen her again okay
dude that that reminds me while you're
talking I'm thinking about parenting
and the power struggles I've got I get
into with my six-year-old
my son was little he was crawling around
the floor pulling off videotapes VHS
tapes right and a buddy of mine who had
older kids was over and I said don't
touch that cabinet and my son would look
at me he'd crawl over and wet that Kevin
and I moved him and I he did a couple
times said if you touch that cabinet
again we're not and I don't know what
the thing was and my buddy goes he's
just laughed and he goes well you over
parented that one and I was like what do
you mean he goes well now none of us are
getting ice cream dinner whatever the
thing was it's like why in in I mean my
son walked right over and just touched
it to see right
and I realized I was in a power struggle
with a two-year-old or the
three-year-old and it's taking wisdom on
this side when my daughter's like
wearing an Elsa dress somewhere like
we're going like to a baseball game it's
500 Degrees I'm wearing this Elsa dress
is this the moment for me to get into a
power struggle right is this right that
took a lot of wisdom where did you get
that wisdom
to sit down with somebody that you knew
like if you worked out three days a week
and changed all of you like I know the
answers that will help you
but that's not the answer that's going
to help you like there's an answer there
was a question beneath that question
yeah and for a year you earned her trust
and for a year you kept showing up and
showing up in her life on her terms and
it was a long game that has changed her
life forever how do you teach somebody
how to pick those battles because that's
that's about wisdom man you know what I
mean yeah you had the answer I screwed
up a lot yeah early I remember I trained
people for a long time now I love
Fitness but I love people more and so my
Saving Grace was that I think that's it
you love people I just wanted to help
them yeah and so I was constantly
evaluating my methods you know I I've
trained a lot of trainers
and there's this this talk that I do
with trainers and I love doing it
because if they haven't heard it always
blows up their minds and I always go
okay uh tell me the most important
traits of a successful trainer as
defined by they get their clients great
results they also built a good business
and it's consistent and the results of
clients are are long long lasting or
forever right what are those traits and
they always say like oh they're
motivating or they're empathetic or they
know a lot of you know they're really
good with information or whatever and I
say those are all important but those
aren't the most important most important
is their ability to communicate
effectively right if you can communicate
if I could like the Matrix if I could
plug my brain into yours and give you my
knowing right we'd solve whatever your
Fitness issue is right right but we can
do that we have to use our words and I
have to understand how to communicate
effectively and so I've through years
and years of failing like I'll tell you
a story it breaks my heart every time I
tell it it's I had this woman who hired
me she wanted to lose weight struggle
with it on and off
and I trained her for a little while and
I also trained her husband
and she was slowly gaining weight uh as
I trained I test I used to test body fat
every week which I stopped doing later
on but I would test body fat every week
to keep people on track right and her
body fat was slowly creeping up and then
I'd have her bring me her food logs
right she'd write down her food and I'm
looking at him like she's only eating
you know I don't remember what it was
1400 1300 calories like this is this is
insane this isn't right so I said are
you writing everything down are you
telling me the truth and yeah yeah I
totally am well anyway I trained her
husband
and her husband uh and he probably
shouldn't have done this but he said hey
Sal I want to tell you something she's
not writing everything down I see at
night she eats this and she doesn't
write it down so she's not be honest
with you so I decided then I'm gonna
have a real hard talk with this lady
yeah so she came in sat down in front of
me and I essentially scolded her right
because that's what I'm supposed to do
I'm a trainer you hire me get in your
shape I'm telling you the truth I'm a
scoldy right and she got in tears and oh
I'm so sorry you're so right whatever
and she walked out and I'm so proud of
myself and she never came back yeah okay
and I failed why did I fail because at
least she was working out twice a week
with me she never she not for all I knew
probably she never worked out again she
had a terrible experience probably never
worked out I totally failed and I looked
back on that I said man I really
screwed up how I communicated yeah was I
right yeah did it help nope yeah I
totally failed uh that poor woman and so
that's where I kind of learned and
figured some of this stuff out and you
got to meet people where they're at and
there's a couple General things that
I've learned to understand one of them
is this is a big one and I know this is
in your space too because you do a great
job of this as well you do a great job
of communicating to where the average
person can listen and understand what
you're trying to say you really get what
you're trying to say so actually why we
invited you on the show
a lot of people in Myspace talk to each
other yeah it's like I'm talking to
other Fitness Fanatics and I realized
this five years into my career
she's not going to become
a fitness fanatic right I am not talking
like if I do the whole you know rah-rah
Rah go in the gym it's great get the
pump that's awesome that's not never
gonna resonate with her you know if it
did she'd become a trainer right or
she'd own a gym so I'm not talking to
Fitness Fanatics I'm talking to the
average person what does the average
person want they want to improve the
quality of their life
they really don't care about getting
shredded everybody's like I want to be
shredded not really I mean okay yeah we
could dream but really people just want
to be fit and healthy they want to be
generally lean not shredded they want to
be generally lean they want to be
generally healthy they want to have good
Mobility I want to have good energy for
my life my fitness improves my life my
life is not Fitness right so I had to
figure that out now what does that mean
well if we do a damn good job
if we do an excellent job as Fitness
professionals the most we could probably
hope for for the average person is about
two or three days a week of structured
exercise we're not going to get more
than that we're just not good luck
though right say what that's humbling
though right what's humbling but also
it's true yeah so two or three days a
week this is if I if I get the average
person who does nothing
exercise-wise structure you know in
terms of structured exercise and I get
them to work out forever two or three
days a week I won you won I'm not
getting more than that you've changed
your family tree that's it so let's stop
pretending and trying to get them to
become Fitness Fanatics it just ain't
gonna happen so now we know that two or
three days a week this is what they're
gonna do so that's number one number two
let's look at food they don't look at
food like a fitness fanatic looks at
Food a fitness fanatic or an obsessive
person or dare I say orthorexics which
is a lot of them in Myspace they look at
food by the way for people that know
orthorexic is uh orthorexia is an eating
disorder where you gotta eat perfect
right so you got bulimia anorexia
orthorexia right there as well they
don't look at food like a like a fitness
fanatic and well that that's just fuel
you ever hear Fitness people say that
food is fuel that's right yeah that's
that's the way of pleasure that doesn't
work that way for most people most
people food is what we said earlier it's
culture it's connecting it's you know
sometimes it's numbing sometimes I'm sad
I'm bored it's pleasure it's all those
different things so we got to understand
those things and then we got to also
understand that this is more of a modern
issue we are very busy but we're also
very sedentary
so
um we are actually busier now than we
were 50 years ago like we were talking
about this earlier we all have kids my
parents didn't scheduled play dates when
I was a kid we just played yeah you want
your kids to play with kids nowadays you
know what you got to do you got to plan
it you got to schedule it it's gonna be
on the calendar yeah you gotta drive
them here drive them there take them
there so we're busy but we're sanitary
so this is what we're working with okay
so how can we figure out
how to put together something that's
effective for people in that context oh
and then one more thing let's add food
is everywhere it's hyper palatable and
it's very cheap so this is what we're
dealing with how can we figure out how
to solve this issue well we talked about
the how we go into it
you got to do this because you're taking
care of yourself not because you're
hating yourself so that's that's the
most important part but now the how well
if you're only going to work out two two
days a week or so consistently let's
pick the form of exercise that's going
to be the most effective
for you long term the form of exercise
that's going to help you stay lean
uh you know keep chronic disease away in
other words what requires the least
amount of time that's going to give you
the most payback biggest payback so
we'll start there for a second if that's
okay
when you look at the weight loss model
it's clearly go by a pair of running
shoes and run five miles a day no
actually we'll get let's talk about that
for a second
when you look at the weight loss model
um you know this is a fact right in
order to lose weight you got to take in
less calories than you burn it's a lot
of thermodynamics or burn more calories
than you take in so that's that's true
now the problem is what we've done is
we've taken that burn calories side of
the equation
and we've valued exercise based off of
how much calories we burn while we do it
because since you got to burn more
calories
let's pick the form of exercise that
burns the most calories and that is
logical it sounds logical the problem is
is it ignores the most important factors
of exercise which is how does this get
my body to adapt and then what do those
adaptations mean that's more important
than how many calories I burn while I do
this exercise in fact how many calories
you burn while you exercise is very very
that's way down the total doesn't mean
very much at all let's look at the
adaptations okay so what kind of
adaptations do we want in our bodies
well if we're only working out two days
a week forget the calorie burn that's
not important even if worked out six
days a week by the way
what adaptations do we want well we're
surrounded by food
we don't move much
what adaptations could we induce in our
bodies that will protect the smokes
build muscle by far building muscle or
the process even just the process of
building muscle or the sending that
signal to your body to build muscle
teaches my body to burn more calories on
its own I develop a faster metabolism
now why is that important well now I can
eat more and maintain a leaner body uh
body fat I can eat more and get away
with more and and I know you're friends
with uh my good friend Lane Norton he
talks about this all the time
when can when calories are appropriate
sugar
fat the types of things that we tend to
demonize that don't matter as much right
you can actually have a high sugar diet
if your calories appropriate all the the
dangers that come from sugar the vas a
lot of them most of them kind of go away
now that's not to say that you won't
feel crappy sure or your appetite your
fluctuations and appetite are gonna be
up and down or your mood right but
that's that's all important yeah but
calories make a big difference so if we
can get your metabolism to speed up we
can negate a lot of those other issues
building muscle yeah uh does that
building muscle also organizes your
hormones in a way that are more youthful
I use the word youthful because that
cells are better but really what does it
mean is it means men are going to have
higher testosterone
women are going to have a more balanced
estrogen and progesterone profile you're
going to see better growth hormone
cortisol is much more appropriate now
why does strength training or resistance
training do that because when I tell my
body to build muscle in order to do so
my body has to organize my hormones in a
way to do so and it just so happens that
the hormone profile that builds muscle
is the same one that you had when you
were in your 20s or your teens I have a
hypothesis tell me if I'm wrong and just
100 chance I could be wrong here
if I think through infertility all the
different testosterone issues we have
the various cancers that are considered
reproductive cancer is there a
possibility that that just Global
hormone disruption has been because
about 100 years ago we just quit
carrying heavy things that's a big part
of it um I'm sure there's more it's
probably multifaceted at least that's
what the research
is a big area for me that I really look
into
um so it's probably more there's
definitely a lot of factors however
strength training directly it's the only
form of exercise that will directly
increase testosterone and increase
Androgen receptor density these are the
receptors that testosterone attaches to
there was a study they did
um I think over the last 10 years was I
want to say it's only been maybe 10
years old maybe less where they tested
the grip strength of college-aged males
college-aged males today have the grip
strength of 65 year olds in 1983 I think
it is to show you how much weaker and it
was what was it
maybe it was a t somebody was mentioned
the other day that grip strength ends up
being one of the longevity markers it's
the it's what's one of the best
um single metrics that can predict
all-cause mortality there's almost
nothing more effective that's wild yeah
grip strength yeah I mean obviously if
you want to the best uh picture you look
at multiple metrics but if you had to
pick one
grip strength is actually a pretty damn
good one and that's one of those causal
but it ends up hey you can catch
yourself in your fall and things like
that but also it usually means I'm doing
other things right that require grip
right yeah it shows that you're you're
weaker Mobility is worse hormones
probably reflect uh that as well and
then lack of movement and weakness
contribute to lots of other things you
talked about cancer strength training
reduces uh your cancer risk by 25
there's no other single form of exercise
that'll do that now getting healthier in
general reduce your cancer risk but just
building muscle yeah will reduce your
cancer risk by about 25 just building
muscle will improve your insulin
sensitivity better than almost anything
else also they have studies on the
severely obese they don't have them lose
weight does it make them build a little
bit of muscle and their insulin
sensitivity improves uh fight measurably
and that's because muscle is a it's one
of the ways we store glycogen which is
where you know when we turn
carbohydrates into it's also very
insulin sensitive tissue so you build
muscle and you get this this great
response with insulin everybody right
now is talking about insulin and it's
rolling mitochondrial Health and
Longevity and all that stuff
um and we know that you know um you know
blood sugar issues and insulin and
pre-diabetes is just this is a massive
massive builds a little bit of muscle so
here so the the complaint
I don't look like Arnold yeah like you
won't my favorite dude I had one of my
close buddies I mean the skinniest guys
I've ever known in college and I got the
I got the Arnold Bible remember there
was like three inches thick are you
kidding me I have it oh you probably got
it oh God I have it somewhere it's all
taped up it's not my favorite book yeah
and I'll never forget his favorite quote
his his famous quote
uh I'm not gonna do that I don't want to
get that big and we all looked like dude
there's no chip but that's that's the
most common thing like I don't want to
lift weights yeah that would be it's
quicker it's easier it's faster I don't
have to go to the gym as much it's not
the beating up your body like running I
don't get that big man yeah okay so that
would be like me saying
I you know I don't want to read
any books on astrophysics because I
don't want to be Stephen Hawkings
yeah I'll just uh yeah or you know I
don't want to swim I don't want to be
you know Michael Phelps
okay so let me break it down so that
people that's the number one when I talk
to women about Street Theater right is
either a I don't I don't feel
comfortable getting crushed under uh
squat bar and two I don't look like
let's address that first I don't wanna I
don't look like let's address that first
one by the way
um I have you know what would shocked me
so much uh well one of the things that
shocked me the most in a good way of
training female clients was the
confidence that they built from getting
stronger specifically because of what
you said getting under something heavy
and lifting it and being stronger yes
and as a man I never really understood
this but I got it I had one of my female
clients explain this to me once I had a
this woman that I trained very
successful CFO Tech you know um
executive very smart woman and she
wanted she was very petite um and we did
strength training and she came back from
a business trip and she was she as she
was telling me she got emotional she
says I gotta tell you something so she
goes this craziest thing happened to me
and I'm like waiting for this crazy
story and she said I put my bag in the
overhead uh you know compartment on the
plane by myself
and she says that I always have to ask a
man or somebody to help me she goes you
know how empowering that is yeah I
thought wow that's that's amazing so
lifting heavy things and doing it
successfully is a very empowering
feeling to anybody who does it but if
you're a woman watching yes it's
challenging but if you do it right first
of all it's very safe and it's a great
feeling all right let's talk about the
muscle thing first off let's talk about
genetic abilities to build muscle so I'm
not going to use Muscle because I'm
going to use height because that's much
more of an obvious more visible one so
if you look at the Spectrum of genetics
on height on one end you have NBA
basketball players on the other end you
have dwarfism okay the vast majority of
us are somewhere in the middle right
okay so let me ask you this besides
going to a professional basketball game
if you've ever done this how many times
in your life have you seen someone
that's seven feet tall yeah very very
like a handful right yeah very rare you
probably remember each time right
because it was so rare okay the types of
genetics required to build muscles like
Arnold Schwarzenegger or a pro
bodybuilder or that female bodybuilder
that looks so crazy or whatever
that is about as rare as that okay so
but it feels like it's everywhere
because it's on in media right it's a
distort it's a distorted
um idea of what you know how just like
if you if you lived in the NBA you think
oh my God I'm six foot five I'm so short
or whatever right so it's just it's not
true by the way if you had those
genetics you would know and no it's not
like it's not like oh I get a little
thicker when I work out no no no you
would be a freak you would be the
biggest strongest person you know all
the time all the time even if you don't
work out okay so that first off that's
number one that's not you you're way
over here somewhere in the middle number
two they also enhance themselves with
anabolic steroids right okay but even
with that I'll tell you something right
now I could take all the anabolic
steroids and growth hormone in the world
I'll never look like Arnold
Schwarzenegger because they just don't
have a genetics all right you could take
those probiables take them off drugs and
they'll still be far more muscular than
than I would ever look yeah uh what's it
say about Lance Armstrong they're like
yes and he's still a better cyclist
exactly so faster don't worry about that
okay
um and also you're not gonna work out
and then wake up tomorrow and be like oh
my God I went too far oh yeah I built
too much muscle I'm too big it's not
gonna happen what'll end up happening is
if you dedicate yourself even if you
train five days a week and you I mean
hardcore strength training you're going
to get a very sculpted shapely Fast
Metabolism physique that's about us
that's what you're gonna get yeah
um for most people now you're just gonna
get you're going to feel tighter when
you touch yourself and you're gonna get
leaner easier as a real also most fit
better yeah and also muscle is uh dense
it takes up
it takes up a little bit more than
three-fourths of the space of body fat
in other words if you gain 10 pounds of
muscle lost 10 pounds of fat you would
lose almost one-fourth of your size
just just to show you the difference in
in weight and intensity and I say that
because
um you know when I say build muscle to
someone who's really really interested
in losing weight they don't want to add
anything on the scale that's right you
know but the scale that just measures
mass I mean you can cut your leg off and
lose 30 pounds and yeah that's not the
kind of weight you know I used to have
this trainer that worked for me
I've talked about her before on the show
too she was this female trainer um and
she was just real petite I think she was
like five one anyway when I would have a
potential member that was a woman who
would say something I don't want to
build too much muscle I'd say okay
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna bring
in one of my female trainers and if you
could guess her body weight within 15
pounds I'll give you a six month
membership for free
you want what do you say and they say
okay let's do this so I call around and
make an announcement you know attention
staff so and so come to my office
in would walk in my female trainer about
5-1 and she was lean right right fit
small I'd say how much do you think she
weighs they'd be like oh
you know 90 pounds 110 pounds 115 pounds
I get on the scale and you know she was
I think she was 138 pounds and it would
blow people's minds I'd say she's she's
got a lot of muscle
she's just very very lean and then I'd
say now tell this person what you ate
yesterday and she'd list off oh I had a
four egg scramble two slices of toast
burrito for lunch that's it she ate that
much because she's got all this calorie
burning Machinery in her body called
muscle and then that usually would win
them over and they'd end up getting a
membership hiring a personal trainer so
yeah the whole like I'm gonna get too
big ain't gonna happen it's not gonna
happen
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591
nmlsconsumeraccess.org Equal Housing
lender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100
Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs are
for select loan types only and not
available in all states or locations
let's project ourselves we are
a mom of three kids and we have
the oldest one's six
and I'm a dad
we can pick you can be the mom I'll be
the dad vice versa
um I've put on 15 pounds over the last
few years
um I I hate the phrase I hear is I want
to get my body back right after kid
number three kid number four
so much garbage out there dude we talked
about another show about influencers and
The Tick Tock ofization of fitness and
weight loss and dealing with food and
Trauma and culture
husband and wife team they're sitting
there they got three kids kids are in
bed and look and say we I want to feel
better
um you started snoring I want to sleep
better I just want to show up better I
want to get a sex life back we want to
change some stuff
what's two or three or four things like
where do they start yeah no there's so
much nonsense that's good now it's gonna
be different from personal of course of
course but uh look at nutrition from a
behavioral standpoint not from
um
mechanisms like counting calories and
Counting uh macronutrients stuff like
that although I think it's important to
know
proteins fats carbs and calories because
you want to have that information start
with behaviors first so here's some easy
ones
one
try to avoid heavily processed foods
that'll usually result in reduction in
calories by itself you get out of your
house just just just try not to eat them
and don't buy them okay okay that's
that's an easy one here's another one
you'll studies will show that you will
cut your calories by about 10 to 15 if
you simply eat when not distracted
okay so you don't have to change your
diet
just eat without looking at your phone
or the TV or basically not being present
okay you'll need about 10 to 15 less
that way so eat whatever you're eating
just sit down and eat and focus on your
food a third one would be don't drink
anything water or otherwise while you
eat okay now there's no magical like you
know fluids with food cause this thing
to happen in the body really what it is
is you just chew your food more and you
slow down gotcha okay these are these
are all behavioral things so don't drink
while you eat don't eat while you're
distracted avoid heavily processed food
if you just did those most people
in my experience let's say somebody
needs to lose 20 pounds or so we'll get
like 10 10 12 15 pounds wow over time
just from doing you know a few of those
things as far as exercise is concerned
uh make the foundation of your routine
strength training okay it speeds up the
metabolism it'll organize your hormones
well and it sets you up better on long
term it's a longevity play yeah it is
because
um and I used to do this all the time
with clients if we did it right at the
end of their 30 pound weight loss they
would eat they would be eating more than
they did when they started hmm okay not
less what you don't want to do is end up
in a position where yeah I lost 30
pounds but now I'm eating 1200 calories
a day my life's miserable like how okay
I got to keep this up forever yeah like
you want to be in a position where you
have room and you're okay and strength
training helps to encourage that okay so
make that the foundation and then I
here's the last one I would say
don't
there's nothing wrong with
cardiovascular training in fact it's
great for health and all that stuff but
don't don't try to burn the calories off
by doing tons and tons of cardio that'll
actually shoot you in the foot it's
actually it so that's like a that's a
that's a shape-shifter moment yeah and
this is something I picked about a
decade ago and I didn't realize that it
wasn't in the popular culture
the damage there right yeah now I run if
I go for a run it's for my it's almost
entirely mental health yeah like it
clears right or uh if I go for a long
bike ride it's for my head right not for
conject right but say that again like
that one that that's got we gotta hit
home on that because that's that's a new
thing for folks yeah so let me explain
that right so there was this uh great
study that Illustrated this um
scientists went and studied the uh the
hadsa tribe which is a modern
hunter-gatherer tribe so they live
presumably the way that we all lived
thousands of years ago so uh they don't
have modern technology they don't they
don't even use agriculture they hunt and
they gather okay so for all intents and
purposes they're way more active than
the average Western Couch Potato I mean
the way that they would Hunt is they
would stalk an animal track it throw
something at it injure it and then run
after it until it got tired miles yeah
to oh 10 miles or whatever and then you
got to bring it all the way back yeah
yeah so tons and tons of activity in
comparison to the average uh Western so
scientists through some pretty
sophisticated testing went down and
tested their metabolic rates how many
calories are these people burning every
single day and what they found was that
they burned generally the same amount of
calories that the average Western Couch
Potato burn and you think how's that
possible well it's an evolutionary
adaptation ah the body's done regulated
well I mean there's no way we would have
survived if humans burned if our
metabolisms had us burning 8 000
calories a day
you couldn't you couldn't stalk and kill
that much food you ain't gonna find
anything yeah so your body adapted to
become more efficient now let's look at
the type of activity that causes that
it's cardio yeah lots and lots of
endurance type training
pairs muscle down because muscle is very
expensive and it teaches the body to
become very efficient with calories
thermal expensive means calorie
expensive Burns a lot of calories yes
right first of all you don't need a lot
of strength to have a lot of stamina I
mean you look at long distance Runners
right they're very skinny not a lot of
muscle you just need a lot of stamina
and because the activity itself is
calorie expensive right doing cardio
does burn more calories per time spent
than anything else your body just learns
to become extremely efficient at what it
does it's an adaptation process so if
the Cornerstone of your workout routine
for weight loss is lots of cardio what
you'll experience is initial weight loss
and a hard plateau and then in order to
get the weight to have to come off even
more you'd have to cut your calories
more or increase your cardio more and
then you end up in this like I'm doing
six days a week an hour of cardio I'm
eating 1200 calories I still got 10
pounds to lose what the hell is going on
you just explained the United States in
the 80s and 90s and early 2000s that's
it right there yeah go take a fitness
class do a spin class go run miles and
miles and miles and miles and eat way
less and just stop and keep eating less
and less and less and less yeah wow yeah
that's that's a totally failing
um strategy what you want to do is you
want to build muscle and feed your body
appropriately to build muscle and
through that process the weight loss
looks different starts off a little
smaller or slower I should say mainly
because it's uh fat loss with some
muscle gain so the scale might show
offsets yeah I might show a couple
pounds but in reality lost more body fat
than you gain in terms of muscle but
then as the metabolism speeds up you get
this kind of Snowball Effect where the
weight loss starts to accelerate and
then it becomes uh much more permanent
and I like to use this analogy you know
um it would be like if I had a an
advanced AI car
that adapted to my driving
behaviors so imagine if I got my car and
every day I drove 350 miles at 30 miles
an hour what would my car look like it
would adapt and turn into this like
energy efficient machine now what if I
got in that car and I did the quarter
mile as fast as I could every single day
right yeah I'd get this huge big back
tires and yeah this engine that just
burned a tremendous amount of energy
right so strength training does that and
that's why it's the best strategy for a
modern lifestyle because it doesn't take
much time and it also speeds up our
metabolism and that's a good thing when
first of all that'd be a bad thing 10
000 years ago you don't want a fast
metabolism ten thousand years ago but
today food is everywhere yeah I want a
fast metabolism that's going to make it
a lot easier for me to navigate this
this landscape where food is so easily
accessible it's hyper palatable
um that's what that's what I want so
building muscle allows us to do that and
there's other look there's other reasons
why I think strength training is so
awesome uh for the average person I mean
it's the only targeted form of exercise
that lets you shape your body no dude
that's not true because there's a button
on uh the elliptical at the gym at the
hotel and it says uh tone it's the tone
button that doesn't work that way for um
it's for buns or whatever for like tone
yeah do you know that word tone the
literal definition the real definition
of tone is is a muscle's ability to
contract yeah the fitness industry took
that and used it as a marketing term and
sold women memberships because they were
afraid of building muscle so they said
no don't worry you're not gonna build
muscle you're just gonna tone you know
muscles don't do that stupid it's not a
thing no they build with a shrink that's
it toning in that sense is building to a
smaller degree that's all it is so as
you build muscle stupid dude they feel
tired it's incredible I know it's
incredible yeah no I'm just gonna um I'm
just gonna do Thigh Master I'm just
gonna work out I just want to lose
weight on my thighs yeah I know you just
didn't do that now spot reduction is
also uh largely a myth but spot shape
lifting Is For Real yeah so like you
could like shape your butt yeah you
could tell I do tons of shaping on my
busy on my arms yeah
funny man you could shape your shoulders
and your back and your posture and your
you can Target build your body and
create this kind of more shapely looking
physique through strength training it's
also very individualizable
um it's the primary form of exercise for
rehab for a reason you know I could do
strength training with anybody yeah I
can't do running with everybody I can't
do swimming with everybody but I can use
resistance in a way to build by the way
resistance training the way that I'm you
know what I'm talking about is using
resistance in a targeted way to build
strength and muscle
that can be any resistance so I want
people to know I want to be very clear
yes that includes weights it also
includes machines it also includes
resistance bands it includes body weight
and so all those arguments about which
one that's just major into the miners
right that's just yeah like just shut up
and do push-ups or go like do something
yes and it has to be appropriate right
right yeah so if I train
if I train someone that does no nothing
no extra no exercise no strength
training very little is needed to induce
any any types of adaptations gotcha if
I'm training you know a top level
athlete well it's gonna be a lot more
to get their body to improve any further
and I want to say that because one of
the biggest mistakes people make with
all exercise is they think the harder
and the more sweat and the more sore
they get the better that's actually not
only is it false it's the opposite but
that feeds into that earlier thing you
were saying because man my head's been
spinning since you
if you don't like if you genuinely
dislike what you see in the mirror
and working out is a
self-flagellation like I'm punishing
myself for looking like this
then the only way to work out is to be
sore that's the only metric is if you're
sore the next day you did it right yeah
and I mean and to perceive it as a
punishment
but as as a good point like a punishment
that yeah I mean it that's been a hard
toggle for me is working out to where
you can work out again tomorrow and then
work out again the next day and then to
see the the the the gains with the Z has
been so much greater right after after
not trying to do I'm gonna blow people's
minds right now uh
soreness means you went too hard it's
not a good thing okay totally disagree
you're wrong that's incredible you know
if you got sore first of all if you're a
little sore that's fine yeah if you're
really sore you you worked out wrong and
working out wrong means you're gonna get
results slower okay not faster it's like
it's almost slower is it physiological
or is it slower because you're going to
go not as hard the next time because
you're sore both okay physiological so
it would be like here's here's what I
mean by physiological if I get a sunburn
am I going to tan faster no no my tan
slower because now I gotta wait for my
body to heal yeah and I'm not going back
out in the sun anymore and I gotta go
and then I gotta and then I gotta start
the process over right so okay here's
here's a good rule of thumb you should
have more energy at the end of your
workout than you do in the beginning you
should leave your workout feeling better
yeah not worse yeah I remember when I
first just I pieced this together with
my clients I used to as a trainer early
on clients would if they canceled there
was a lot of reasons why people cancel
the workouts but often they'd be
something like um I'm really tired I
didn't get good sleep my shoulder kinds
of hurts I need to skip this workout and
that was common as I got better and more
effective I would get these phone calls
hey silent you know I'm really tired you
have any time on your schedule for a
workout or you know my shoulder hurts
you think I could come see you so I can
work on that a little bit that's why I
knew I was I was so let me say this
crazy thing happened and here I am been
lifting my entire life
so it's a big deal for me one of the
things I tell people all the time is
don't ever plan to do nothing right when
it comes to retirement like I just want
to retire yeah I want to work 50 years
so that I can do nothing for seven and
then die right all the metrics say the
moment you start doing nothing your life
falls apart
but when it came to vacationing that was
me I would run myself into the ground I
would never take vacations and then I
would stay up late back in the night
before and I didn't really want to go
I'm trying to answer emails and then we
would go we'd get somewhere in the
evening I would be kind of burnt out so
we'd eat a little too much I'd probably
have an extra drink and I wouldn't sleep
next morning we'd have plans like let's
just sleep in three days in like my wife
does not want to talk to me and I don't
want to talk to her book we just got
back from our 20th and we did it
different for the first time ever took
20 years to figure this out we got where
we were going we went straight to the
gym and just worked out just exercised
like to we've been sitting in a car for
six hours and then the next morning we
had a long hike up a mountain I brought
my Rook bag with me we just we were
mobile yeah dude by day three I was had
settled into a rest that I didn't
understand I don't think I've ever
experienced it my sleep was super deep
and we were staying more active and the
more active we got together
so my relationships were getting good
more active I got the more rest I had
man and it's totally counterintuitive
but I would have thought you should eat
a bunch and drink a lot and hang out
just come out completely out that's the
on the off on off the wagon you know on
the wagon off the wagon mentality we
tend to do with exercise nutrition it's
either all on or all off and we it's
hard for us to achieve a balance because
either I hate myself or I oh no I said I
want to hate myself anymore I just want
to enjoy life you know type of deal
um which you know that's that's again
that's why people lose weight gain it uh
all the time no you you want to feel
better
after your workout than you did before I
love that you want to feel good that's
been a big shift for me and you want to
treat your and here's the other thing
too I remember you know a long time ago
I was hiking up in the Foothills over
here in California and uh I you know
people would pass me Runners would pass
me and it's it's hard as a trainer it's
hard for me not to notice biomechanics
right so I'm sure just like you you hear
people talk it's hard to talk to their
kid I'm like I shouldn't say that yeah
yeah exactly so people run by like oh my
God that guy's feet so pronating oh look
at that person's anterior pelvic tail
that's gonna really hurt and then this
guy ran by he looked like a gazelle and
he just ran so beautifully and you know
and it heard me I'm like you know
humans evolve to do a few things really
well physically one of them's run we
actually can outrun for distance when
we're fit and all that stuff pretty much
any other animals yeah that's how we
hunted we throw with accuracy we do that
really well then we run them down right
like why can nobody run properly I said
oh I know why nobody realizes it's a
skill
when people want to start working out
they lace up their shoes and they go get
they just go to get tired
or soar yeah like I'm just gonna run
until I'm tired and I thought my God
people do this with spring training too
they don't go to the gym and say oh I'm
gonna go practice the skill of squats
I'm gonna go get my legs sore I'm not
gonna go practice the skill of rows I'm
gonna go get my back sore
the way you need to trade treat strength
training if you really want long-term
success is it's a skill so when you go
to the gym stop thinking about getting
sore and beating yourself up instead
think all right today's workout is going
to be I'm going to squat
I'm gonna uh bench press I'm gonna row
and I'm gonna overhead press or I'll
pick four really good exercises I'm
gonna go practice them and get real good
at them and every time you go whatever
two days a week three days a week you
practice exercises and you try to get
better at them that's all you're trying
to do to get better at those skills and
you know we'll get you'll what you'll
get from that amazing consistent results
and you won't get hurt consistent
amazing results and you won't get hurt
and you'll enjoy it it's way more
enjoyable I promise you dude that's a
that's the exact same thing when it's
like
I'd have a hard conversation with your
spouse practice it yeah just get better
at it how do you sit down and talk to
your kids about hard conversation
practices just go do it and figure it
out and then go do it again and then go
do it again go do it again that's it and
over time you'll get stronger yes your
form will get better the technique will
get better also you know when it comes
to exercise there's uh you know if I
were to give them a rating like zero to
a hundred a hundred being the most value
I could get out of an exercise zero
being none the better you perform the
exercise the better your skill is at
that exercise the more I'm going to
derive from it if I'm really good at
squatting that good control good
technique good connection I'm gonna get
great results out of it if I don't have
good skill and technique with it I'm not
going to get good results out of it I'll
probably hurt myself yeah so I want to
feel better at the end of my workout
have good energy I don't want to get
sore or if I do maybe a little bit I
want to practice these exercises and I
want to focus on strength training
that's really the gist of it can you
imagine if we treated other sports this
way by the way yeah I mean people people
like I'm gonna go play basketball lose
weight and they just ah go as hard as
they can so they get sore yeah dude
acl's flying off you wouldn't be playing
basketball I mean and the truth is you
don't need exercise design when you work
out that way I don't care what you do do
whatever you want you're gonna get the
same results you're just gonna get sore
and beat yourself up
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
over the course of this conversation
you've talked about I was this kind of
trainer and then I was that kind of
trainer
I think we've got a cultural illness
where we have an inability to say the
words I was wrong
and you've got some like you've been
pretty humble about that right pretty
open about like I used to think this was
the right way then I worked with people
I was not afraid to go get information
from somebody else ask them wisdom how
do I talk to this person here what's the
best way
and how do you coach people here's what
I'm struggling like and I was I was we
were talking offline about Lane
dude I used to have spreadsheets
I'm a nerd right I had spreadsheets
about what I had my I bought my own
glucose mod I wanted to know what my
body did when it was vegan when it was
my wife used to come like every month
when we were doing our monthly budget be
like what are we this month are we keto
what are we doing because I just want to
track it and find it
and then I had to have like some time of
grieving it to be like no it's just
really just follow the macros and it's
calories in calories out just don't be
stupid and you deloni you you can't
control gummy bears and so you just
gotta abstain you just don't
that's hard for me man it was hard for
me to say those words because I had
spoke publicly about the keto diet and
add more fat and cholesterol nobody you
shouldn't care about cholesterol
triglycerides mean nothing I was I would
run my mouth about that in public
settings I would tell individuals about
that I would take over dinner parties
telling people like you know what
and then I sat down on the Buddy's a
scientist and I had to look in the
mirror and go I was wrong like how do
you learn the wisdom how do you learn
the humility there and then how do you
change positions you've been telling
somebody you can be doing this doing
this no you gotta do something different
yeah if we could all learn that I think
the culture would shift oh man I wish I
knew that the easy answer of that you
know I I'll tell you something that
impacted me quite a bit years ago I had
this woman that I trained and you know
I'll take a step back
I loved training people for a lot of
different reasons one of them was very
selfish so I got to train
so many different personalities and so
many different people different
professions that um I love learning and
I love people I love studying people I
love listening to people and so I got to
train and I would ask all these
questions and it just so it turns out
that people like talking about
themselves so it worked out really well
right but I would ask all these
questions and I loved learning from all
these different people that were so
smart you know I talked to surgeons
about surgery and medicine and I had
clients that were psychologists and I
had clients that you know were married
for 60 years and I asked them all these
different questions well anyway I had
this woman
and she was just she blew me away
because she was so balanced and
well-versed on almost any topic so we
would debate or discuss a topic and she
did this she had this ability to be able
to argue both sides and understand both
ends and just she was so good
and I I asked her I said where did you
learn this like how do I figure this out
she said well she goes
try this she goes
um try to find people who have an
opposing view from you who are smart
and then
be open-minded to having your mind
changed and then start a discussion with
them and and try not to be an [ __ ]
she said that because you know if you
get confrontational people don't want to
it's over yeah so [ __ ] try to find these
people and ask them honest questions and
go ahead and discuss with them and
debate with them but do in a way to
where you're open okay and I said okay
I'm gonna do that so what I did is I
went on Facebook
and I signed up for all these different
groups I still do this I still have all
these different groups this is by the
way great hack you can sign up for
groups of things that you want to learn
like neuroscience and they will they
will pick the best studies and break it
down for you don't have to do the work
because you got a bunch of
neuroscientists and students in there
that'll do it and you can read the
comments and hear them debate and I
don't need to do any of the work it's
all on that right so I would go to all
these different groups and I would go in
there and I would start discussions with
people well why do you think this and
what's going on here and I'd be
open-minded and I remember the first
time the first few times I got my mind
changed where I was like man I was wrong
and it was a great feeling yeah it was
better it's a it's a great feeling
because I don't have to be and now I can
be right or now I get I'm closer to
truth right so I think you have to have
that attitude where being right you know
personally is not as important as
finding the truth yes right when my
identity is in I gotta be right then I
gotta I gotta go to the bottom of the
ocean on that topic if my identity is in
loving will I want to help people or
only a culture the truth man then yeah
you welcome being wrong right totally um
and I had to learn this also because of
my life for people because you know how
many times my Paradigm got shattered
with clients I can't yeah I can't
imagine oh my God because you know
there's so many when it comes to health
and fitness uh I'm sure you see this too
with with mental stuff with mental
health there's so many individual
variances like I remember once I had
this client who very smart man
anesthesiologist uh loved him my good
friend of mine still
and um
he did a smart guy and he used to also
donate his time he'd do the Doctors
Without Borders so he'd go you know
across the world and you know donated
services to help you know children who
you know have certain issues whatever
and he'd go over and do this stuff and
he lived in this uh for it was like a
three-month period he lived in this
Village that was largely vegan okay so
he lived there and he came back and he
you know I was asking about about this
trip or whatever and he goes you know
what man
I felt really good eating vegan now I'm
at the time I'm like look studies show
meat is nutrient dense you need proteins
you need this you need that so it's like
counter everything that I believe and
I'm like no no no no I think it was
other factors that made you feel good
you need all these nutrients humans
evolved eating me or whatever and we
went back and forth for a little while
and then I said you know what Sal I was
talking to myself I said stop being so
arrogant like if he feels better let's
see what happens right so I did I had
him go vegan and it turned out he had
some intolerance a lot of intolerances
to animal products and he just felt
better now that wasn't most my clients
but that was him right and it shattered
my paradigms you know I gotta start
listening to people more than trying to
always be right and you just run into
that all the time with individual
variances oh this is the truth and this
is the right thing and then you got the
one person well not for them
and so that that really molded and
shaped me you know kind of who I am now
and it's still a journey I mean I know I
still I'm still fall into that same you
know old pattern but luckily you know I
I've developed that habit I think of
you know I'll pause or usually it's
after a debate or argument usually it's
later on after I think I did a good job
and I'll be at home and I'll be like
well was I open-minded maybe maybe I was
being a little arrogant and hard-headed
you know it was that great Charlie
Munger quote and I'll butcher it but
you cannot publicly State an opinion
until you can
publicly State your opponent's opinion
better than they can right and if you
take the time to be that thoughtful then
we'd all talk a little bit less
um I I'm just I guess I'm caught off
guard by this one's this one's bothering
me usually I love when I find out I'm
wrong I always invite people on the show
me if I say something psychologically
inaccurate call me on it dude I'll read
it
this one's bothering me and I think I
just invested so much of my identity and
being a counter-cultural diet guy yeah
and the systems that
I think I I think I made it an identity
in fact saying out loud I know that's
what I did I made an identity and then I
had to die on the whatever Hill that was
you know how they say um you know when
you're at a dinner party don't discuss
uh politics and religion right throw
diet in there a thousand percent yeah
people identify strongly to their diet
some more than others
um and a lot of some of it's have been
politicized which is very interesting
I've never seen diets be politicized but
you're starting to say that now dude
yeah everything's being politicized it's
amazing but people identify so strongly
with their diets um here's some general
truths and then there's a lot of
variants General truth don't overeat
for the most part whole natural foods
are better so I don't care if you're
vegan or paleo or carnivore or you know
whatever Mediterranean whole Natural
Foods
don't overeat and then here's the other
one we I don't care what diet you're on
or whatever you can develop
dysfunctional relationship with food
um and it comes from things that have
nothing to do with losing body fat or
gaining weight it's usually a way to
cope a way to numb a way to distract
um it's one of those things this is why
like I said earlier uh some of the best
uh diet studies or success or people
just go to therapist yeah yeah at um a
close friend of mine asked recently
wait a minute
I used to always wonder about we're
gonna have dinner we're gonna have food
at home
could that be why every time we go out I
over order and then I always order way
too much and I was like for sure man
like your body's remembering oh yeah oh
yeah and so but it's pulling that thread
right oh absolutely I mean my family you
said this earlier my I'm the first
generation American and
um my family's from Sicily poor very
poor Sicilians um so my dad very poor
you know six siblings and shared a room
with all his siblings and all that stuff
and then my grandparents my you know
forget about it the stories they tell me
is pretty crazy so I was raised where
they literally would put food in I mean
if you didn't have food in your mouth
then then there was something wrong
constantly but that was like an
objective measure of we're going to be
all right is our kids will never be
hungry right we will solve for that yes
yes like well bro listen that wasn't
that was ingraining me to the point
where I was doing it to my own kids yeah
and I didn't become aware of it until
later on yeah where am I no you better
finish everything and this is what
you're gonna you played yeah yeah and I
was like oh wait a minute what am I
doing here yeah to the point where I
would like bribe them if you finish that
I'll give you this oh all day oh dude
yeah and I was like oh yeah it's my own
thing I got raised with so well dude
your hospitality is just top-notch and
just beating great people over country
I'm so grateful to meet you thank you
for your hospitality and your wisdom
thanks for sharing it with us and for
real thanks for uh being my therapist
for a while that was I needed to talk I
hadn't thought about some of this stuff
ever so it's good for this to come out
organically but I'm grateful for you
brother thank you so much we appreciate
it man thanks very much thanks John